welcome to cbs this morning those kind
of photo finishes never
ever get older i know what i love about
it bruins were an
underdog yeah a different role for them
tony we have somebody new at the table
adriana diaz and you're here all week
i'm here all week so happy to be here
oh and you know what we're happy to have
you thank you dale good to see you
adriana
we're going to begin with this in just a
few hours opening statements will begin
in the highly anticipated trial of
derrick chauvin
he is a fired minneapolis police officer
accused of murdering george floyd
10 months ago by kneeling on his neck
for over nine minutes they say now
according to the
court documents a bystander recorded the
arrest and that video fueled one of the
largest protest movements in
u.s history demonstrators around the
world demanded an
end to police brutality and systemic
racism
and last night members of the floyd
family joined his supporters at a prayer
vigil
and rally in minneapolis and that's
where we find our jamie yukis outside
the courthouse where the trial will be
held jamie
good morning to you good morning tony
the trial is expected to last up to four
weeks you can see all the security
measures including that fencing in place
around the courthouse this morning city
and state officials could spend
up to tens of millions of dollars in
preparation for potential chaos
once a decision is made in this high
profile case
[Applause]
from an afternoon protest outside the
courthouse
[Music]
to a prayer vigil sunday night hosted by
national civil rights figure al sharpton
the demand for justice in george floyd's
death continues
more than 10 months later is america
prepared
to hold police accountable today the
trial of fired minneapolis police
officer derek chauvin
a 19-year veteran begins and for the
first time in minnesota
a case will be televised and live stream
for all to see
minneapolis attorney joe tamborino have
you ever seen a trial like this
never i mean we have walls we have
fencing concertina wire
national guard police it's a little
unnerving
tamborino who has no connection to the
case says the trial has already been
unusual seating a jury took more than
two weeks
14 will be seated that's all we have
room for
why do you think it's important
specifically to this case that people
see it
transparency because in this day and age
there's so much distrust with government
that to actually have a completely
transparent process is extremely
important
the prosecution is expected to rely on
the video footage of chauvin
kneeling on floyd's neck while the
defense will argue the fentanyl found in
floyd's system
along with his underlying health
conditions contributed to his death
day one you're going to see both parties
come out of the chute strong from the
prosecution side they're going to be
arguing unreasonable force
from the defense side they're going to
be arguing cause of death
a diverse set of jurors will examine the
evidence in this case the panel of 15
includes nine people who are white and
six who are black or multiracial
one person will be dismissed today if
all 15 show up
that means 50 percent of the core 12
jurors could be black or multiracial
compared to 17 percent of the county's
population gail
jamie thank you very much